[Música]
cinco anos atrás eu ainda estava na
faculdade onde cursava engenharia de
produção eu vivi uma cena que me marcou
e até hoje ela me incomoda quando lembro
dela era um dia comum você já deve ter
vivido isso entrega de prova e que
aconteceu nesse dia e tão diferente
entregou as provas já começou a lhe
conferir as notas aí vai ter batido em
que se aquilo o amigo meu levanta e vai
com duas provas na mesa da professora
a gente chega na mesma professora na
verdade a gente chega na mesa da
professora e mostra as duas provas pela
professora eu acredito que deve ter um
erro aqui nessa prova aqui
essa questão está colocada como correta
mas na minha e rada eu conferi as duas
aqui dizendo a mesma coisa única
diferença é que na minha conta com as
minhas palavras da professora pegou as
duas provas morreu assim rapidamente
colocou do lado virou pra ele falou
marcel a correção na correta e deixa eu
te falar uma coisa
deixa pra usar suas palavras quando você
for doutor escutar deixe para usar suas
palavras quando você for doutor é
complicado escutar um negócio desse e na
verdade isso nenhum educador deveria
falar na vida porque essa professora em
outras palavras que ela estava dizendo
para marcela tá falando marcel eu não tô
nem aí se você estudou se você aprendeu
se você interpretou se você conseguiu
através das suas palavras expressar
aquilo que já deveria ter aprendido
pra mim o importante é citar igual o
autor colocou se você coluna não chego
na resposta do autor o que importa é que
essa professora estava dizendo a marcel
e de outras formas com outros exemplos
você já deve ter vivenciado uma situação
assim não especificamente de ser doutor
e tal mas aprender por obrigação sem
saber por que está aprendendo e outras
coisinhas mais que acontece no nosso
processo educacional
esse é o tipo de coisa que diversas
vezes me incomodou
eu era criança quando era pequenininha
ali minhas tias minha mãe é contar a
história para mim e na hora da
chapeuzinho entrar na floresta sozinha
falava mas porque ela está sozinha
a cabine pentelho sabe por quê por quê
porque quando me satisfazia a via está e
depois ou seja não contava com um
pouquinho a igreja reza a história que
vivi isso essa indignação é porque eu
fui ensinado fui condicionado e tem um
exemplo questionador na minha vida
educacional houve muitas coisas que eu
ficava dando a palavra [ __ ] é isso vai
ficar puto e aí eu olhava para um lado
ou para o outro
discuti com meus pais são professores
mas aquilo que consumir quando esse caso
até hoje lembra o menino
esse é o tipo de coisa que me fez mesmo
engenheiro formado queria dedicar meus
dias pra educação pra fazer diferente e
para fazer diferente
mesmo na educação e resolvi não ficar na
educação tradicional porque a educação
tradicional é pelo nome tradicional eu
não conseguiria fazer muito diferente
ele eu resolvi para o mercado o chamado
mercado de cursos online cursos livres
alguém já deve ter visto e são aqueles
cursos não regulamentados pelo mec os
cursos online
lá eu ia tenha liberdade criativa e
diferente e poder testar uma parada meio
louca
fui pra lá e comecei a viver esse
mercado testar algumas coisas diferentes
e comecei a enxergar que esse mercado
diferente do que estava imaginando que
era adquirida em educação supletiva esse
mercado tem um outro lado que era as
bases desse mercado não fundamentadas no
marketing
então o foco é a venda marketing está
muito aluno dentro e aprendizagem que
ficava nessa hora eu parei me questionei
ranieri será que
empacotar de outra forma você não está
cometendo os mesmos erros que aquela
professora cometeu quando falou para
marcel esperar pra ser doutor paulo está
com as palavras dele a resposta a esse
questionamento foi uma coisa que me doeu
que a última coisa que queria fazer a
isso e talvez eu tivesse fazendo
e aí eu olhei para esse mercado me vi me
senti um pouco padre às vezes gastando
marketing e deixando a educação de lado
em segundo plano mas por trabalhar com
criatividade também deu um estalo falei
tá mas essa é a primeira eu deixar o
marketing de lado e voltar 100% no mundo
da educação a primeira resposta certa
mas talvez eu possa enxergar isso de uma
outra maneira de maneira criativa e foi
assim que eu tenho que enxergar esse
movimento é movimento é esse eu olhei
para o mar que eu falei
será que isso é realmente um competidor
da educação isso pode ser inspiração pra
mim uma pessoa que totalmente de
principiante que não conhece as bases
não conhecia no caso base de paulo
freire maria montessori outros grandes
educadores minha cabeça livre sem
amarras em tendências sem preconceitos
preconceitos preconcebidas e fez disso
uma vez olhando desse jeito o meu
diferencial
e foi isso que o impacto teve aqui falar
pra vocês hoje o que eu chamei de o que
os educadores não aprenderam
é muita pretensão é que ela vem e não é
cidade e falar o que os educadores não
aprenderam que microfantasia o mix traz
como professor eu brincava apanhava
mas vamos lá o que os educadores não
aprenderam a mexer o marketing porque o
marketing porque o marketing
ele é um pouco diferente vocês vão
entender um pouquinho o que eu quero
dizer com isso quando ele exemplifica
com três pontos de como o marketing pode
usar é como a gente pode usar o
marketing para potencializar o nosso
processo educacional mais para fazer na
educação diferente mas não diferente por
diferente diferente que funciona
o primeiro desses pontos eu chamei de
conheça
é o que o marketing o foco no cliente
isso aí todo mundo já sabe que não vou
fazer uma venda tem a primeira coisa é
conhecer o meu cliente nosso processo
educacional
será que a gente está conhecendo a fim
do nosso cliente
eu sei se meu cliente é um homem se a
mulher se ela é uma mulher é uma
japonesa uma brasileira possui alguma
necessidade especial e no fundo a noite
que faz é isso é conhecer mais a fundo e
sobre quem é essa persona que o meu
cliente eu descobrindo isso eu vou saber
quais são os seus sonhos quais são seus
desejos quais são as suas frustrações
isso aqui é input para desenhar o meu
processo de aprendizagem da melhor
maneira possível é o entender essa
empatia
quando eu olho pra isso aqui ainda tem
alguns pontos quando ele precisa aqui eu
me lembro seguinte processo educacional
o processo de transformação onde tem o
objetivo de fazer um outro aprender
alguma coisa esse aprendizado tem que
servir para os e servir pra quê
para levar a ele um passo a mais a
caminho do seu sonho pra resolver uma
frustração e aí a gente se pergunta
também quais são os fatores que essa
pessoa leva em consideração para tomar a
decisão
quando penso nisso imagina uma uma
criança adolescente que está passando
pelo processo educacional e vai fazer um
vestibular o enem daqui a pouco e você
falar pra ele
se você estudar matemática você não vai
passar no vestibular
mas o fator de decisão mais importante
para ele é um amor descobrir novas
coisas
só vai faltar afastando mais ele no
interesse e não aproximando e trazendo
um pouco mais essa é esse conceito de
pessoal promovido nacional com as suas
formas de aprender que o meu aluno que o
meu aprendiz está mais familiarizado com
o que funciona melhor para ele é lei é
ouvir é lei houve é ver um vídeo é v12
falando aqui na frente e meio como estou
fazendo aqui agora o quê
é a educação mais padrão a educação
diferenciada tem vários caminhos pra
isso ea gente só vai saber no momento em
que a gente dialogar num momento em que
a gente se abrir a conversar pra
entender o outro uma vez que a gente
entende a gente tem que passar o próximo
passo que é compreender e esse é o
segundo ponto eu quero trazer para vocês
no marketing não só desenhar pessoa
importante compreender é um processo de
empatia empatia pura se colocar no lugar
do outro
quando falo empatia eu me lembro de uma
frase que é tem o rodrigo geribello que
ele fala e se essa frase com a distância
do seu entendimento o entendimento do
outro
essa frase a frase que todo jogador
deveria se fazer
ao começar o processo educacional porque
no final das contas o processo
educacional o processo de
conscientização eu vou concientizar do
conhecimento que eu tenho eu vou
transferir essa consciência e quando
falo em consciência me lembra uma
ferramenta do marketing
lembro que falei pra vocês que muitas
ferramentas do marketing para
potencializar exigiam aquela ferramenta
do marketing chamada funil da
consciência
ali em cima quem as pessoas que estão
inconscientes do problema por exemplo
próxima semana vou pra natal minha
cidade eu tenho consciência que eu posso
passar frio natal dezembro um calor
danado lá só que imaginei que esse é um
processo de venda de um casaco
o vendedor quer me vender e fazer o
processo de marketing e ele sabe que vai
ter uma frente fria na próxima semana em
natal
quando ele me fala isso ele passa a me
conscientizar que eu posso passar à
frente natal que eu saio do primeiro
estágio para o segundo o segundo estágio
consciente do problema quando eu tô
consciente desse problema que acontece
comigo eu começo se é uma dor que eu
sinto começa a buscar alternativas que
eu posso fazer para não passar frio e
natal
a primeira coisa eu posso ir para natal
é uma possibilidade
eu posso enrolado num lençol posso lutar
cinco camisetas ou posso comprar um
casaco
se eu ficar falando aqui a gente quer
ficar que ficar falando dia todo e
possibilidades mas aí eu começa a
cogitar as soluções e desse mais um
degrau fique consciente das possíveis
soluções
e é nesse momento que o vendedor pode
chegar para mim falar em ataque um
casaco 1990 contra o filho passa frio
natal
e aí eu vou lá decidiu comprar ou não
agora quando a gente olha pra cá lembra
o nosso processo educacional que
acontece com conteúdo quando um educador
vem trazer pra gente
você tem que aprender isso aqui paulo e
todo o conteúdo
pra que serve não sei pauta um conteúdo
é isso que acontece
mas não é conscientizado hoje não passa
pelo funil é importante entender isso é
importante entender isso se a gente quer
se colocar no lugar do outro se está
passando por um processo de empatia
preconceitos a outro e aí quando a gente
entende que a gente tem que entender
essa distância vem mais uma pergunta que
eu quero trazer também uma frase do
rodrigo pra contextualizar isso aqui
dentro do meu conhecimento que eu
escolhi para gerar interesse em fazer
com que a pessoa que tá aprendendo além
de outro lado que era mais a gente sabe
muita coisa
às vezes é a maldição de conhecimentos
há muita coisa nem por onde começar
quando vai passar a mensagem de que vai
despertar esse interesse
segundo ponto o terceiro ponto é
converter o processo de marketing
depois que eu passei por todo o funil de
venda eu tenho que converter aquele
processo todo uma venda
esse é o grande objetivo no processo da
educação que conversão é essa que eu
busco aprendizagem é fazer com que o
outro aprenda ps não tem sentido está
ensinando
então pra o converter eu vou fazer
acertar no alvo e pra acertar no alvo
tem que entender qual é o passo a passo
que o meu aprendiz passa nesse processo
de aprendizagem
na corrida de 100 metros da maratona ea
maratona quem já fez maratona eu
obviamente não fiz mas eu sei como é que
funciona você vai passo a passo
você planeja os primeiros um quilômetro
depois os primeiros cinco depois o
primeiro e você vai passo a passo
planejando entendendo como funciona esse
caminho e é pra isso existe uma
ferramenta do marketing que se chama
jornada do cliente é o entender
antes durante e depois como é que
funciona a cabeça da minha persona
segundo os diversos critérios que ele
faz é que ele pensa que ele sente
vocês passaram por lá jornada como essa
num determinado dia você descobriu que
existe um movimento pede pedex depois se
descobriu que tem um aqui magras
chegaram lá descobrir quanto era pagar o
compraram chegaram hoje de manhã o
acordaram se vestiram vieram pra cá
estão passando aqui por diversas
palestras tratando durante ali viviam
vários conteúdos algumas dinâmicas
depois vamos sair daqui hoje falando pra
todo mundo te adorar uma palestra e no
final das contas vão estar
compartilhando os vídeos que vão surgir
aqui
esse é um processo quando eu entendo
esse processo no âmbito do marketing
vendas
eu consigo mapear as objeções de
oportunidades que surgem a partir daí o
que a objeção objeção é como o nome
fábio fábio chegou na hora de comprá lo
é caro
não entendo que ele acha caro eu tenho
que mostrar mais valor para ele com quem
enxergue mais o valor e com que o preço
seja meio é baixo com relação ao valor
ganha mais valor que eu vou pagar no
processo educacional que objeções são
essas
talvez depois desse dia de palestras tem
a gente cansada aqui dever tanto
conteúdo é muita informação nova
entender isso no processo de
aprendizagem ajuda porque são objeções e
ao mesmo tempo há oportunidades a todos
vocês vão sair daqui falando alguma
coisa
são oportunidades para impactar mais
pessoas até pra vocês mesmos aprender
porque eu não sei se vocês sabem mas
existe uma pesquisa da que estuda as
formas de aprender que fala que a melhor
forma de aprender você ensinar
então se você sair daqui ensinando vocês
aprenderam fica a dica vão aprender
muito mais
e pra isso é importante entender que uma
jornada de aprendizagem processo de
aprendizagem
ele é trilha e não é trilho ele não é
fixo
o desenho caminho a trilha ali mas a
gente tem que entender que ele precisa
ser mutável porque cada um tem sua forma
de aprender a educar que mais se conecta
com você mesmo e talvez você esteja se
perguntando raniere que é educado agora
deve tá olhando ganhar eu já vi isso
inconsciente de grandes educadores como
falei aqui no começo o paulo freire
bigot vygotsky e outros mais
isso aí já aí está sendo de uri eu como
educador não sabia isso é o que eu
aprendi
existe um tempero do marketing que
talvez faça toda a diferença
inclusive explicitado nesses exemplos
que eu trouxe o marketing e talvez seja
isso que os educadores não aprenderam
ele é sexy
o marketing ele é sexy
ele é persuasivo ele gera interesse ele
gera aquela coisinha dentro de você fica
num interessante
algumas vezes é verdade é vulgar mas na
maioria das vezes elas antes como por
exemplo eu quero vender uma fita adesiva
eu posso mostrar a fita funcionando
eu quero mostrar que a cidade
inteligente eu posso demonstrar isso na
prática a ibm fez isso tenho soluções
para cidades inteligentes desenvolveu na
prática mostrou ali está funcionando
eu posso mostrar por que um homem
precisa de creme anti-rugas uma foto
aí bateu o carro simplesmente fuga e por
aí vai
então o mar que tem essa pegada sexy
essa pegada diferente e talvez seja isso
o tempero que a gente esteja precisando
da educação para finalizar
eu queria deixar uma pequena reflexão a
provocação para vocês
da próxima vez que você estiverem
conversando com os seus aprendizes e
como aprendizes interno não só os seus
alunos mas um parceiro é parceiro de
negócio o parceiro dentro de casa um
colega de trabalho seu líder os seus
liderados
qualquer aprendiz que esteja qualquer
pessoa que esteja aprendendo com você
da próxima vez que você estiver em
ensinando alguma coisa no processo de
aprendizagem dos seus aprendizes lembrem
se a educação não é sobre forma a
educação sobre transformar muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]